y una nueva caravana de migrantes son
más de 2000 personas salen desde la
ciudad de tapachula en el sur de méxico
y buscan llegar a estados unidos que me
falle esta está en la peor situación
económica
delincuencia
bruna no hay estudios no hay educación a
los hijos es por eso tomamos la
determinación yo y mi esposa de venirnos
pues para ver si podemos lograr nuestro
objetivo más al norte en nuevo morelos
los migrantes aseguran que las
autoridades mexicanas les están
ofreciendo residencia temporal a cambio
de no avanzar hacia eeuu según el
instituto nacional de migración de
méxico unas 1500 personas han accedido
pero en este grupo todavía quedan varios
centenares no se fían de las promesas y
las oportunidades económicas crecen en
el norte del país está pensado para
ayudar a inmigrantes y no para de
disolver la caravana por eso es que
tienen tantos errores porque no se hace
de una forma humanitaria sino de una
forma de contención
las caravanas surgieron hace años como
una forma para los migrantes de huir de
narcotraficantes y la inseguridad pero
las policías de guatemala y méxico están
aumentando la represión para disolverlas
el presidente de eeuu joe biden
prometido tratarlos con más humanidad
que su predecesor donald trump sin
embargo desde su llegada a la casa
blanca 1,3 millones de personas han sido
detenidas en la frontera cifra récord en
20 años